Daniel Birnbaum is the company's global
CEO and joins me now so when this guy
continued gone buy bottled water anymore
but you're really suggesting these
people should be hounded in the streets
no but I think they should be using tap
water because it's perfectly safe and
it's much more environmental and it's
much more economical this was quite
controversial though because you were
taken to court for targeting water
rather than other soft drinks not to
court but we got a pile of letters from
the likes of coca-cola and Nestle who
really have reason to concern because we
are challenging their antiquated
business model billions and billions of
bottles sugar cost slepping it's all
wrong and we're saying do it in a
different way
Coke alone does a 100 billion plastic
bottles a year so they have reason to
send us a lot of letters indeed we have
their UK boss on last week telling us
how they're trying to cut back on that
but there it goes again
what about yum this is obviously a
really important issue on about 2050
we're gonna have more plastic in the in
the oceans then then fish but I mean
let's be honest I mean you just run this
shift more of your own project product
with this on me
look there's nothing wrong in promoting
a cause which is a an honest and a moral
cause that also promotes your business
do I have to not promote it I mean I
think Mark Twain is the one who's quoted
saying you're never wrong doing the
right thing and in this case doing the
right thing is eliminating the plastic
waste and SodaStream offers a solution
take tap water use a reusable bottle
save money less sugar it's great it's
fun it's happy why not now separately
you've you've been launching make your
own beer in Germany in Switzerland we
plan to bring it here as well yeah
SodaStream is a magical device you take
tap water and you put bubbles in it in a
few seconds you can add some flavour or
squeeze some lemon put some cucumbers in
there add some vodka or rum or whatever
and you can also make beer with it so
yes we do plan to at least try the beer
here it's doing fabulously where we are
testing it right now in some of our
markets such as Germany and Italy and
Austria we do plan to bring it here in
time and briefly Germany the US and
France are your biggest markets globally
how big is the UK by comparison UK is
still smaller than Germany but we're
very hot here
the whole region I can't give specific
data for one country because we're a
public company traded on nasdaq but the
region is growing at a pace of 16% we're
hitting the hot buttons with the
consumer we come from the UK so pretty
much everybody knows SodaStream so we're
back all right down your burn ban from
SodaStream gonna leave it there thanks
for joining me